[Musique]
le grand
Asier dès la première moitié du 19e
siècle les grandes propriétés rurales se
multiplient à sainte suusanne et
s'inscrivent durablement dans le paysage
de cette commune de l'Est parmi elles le
grand
Asier la famille Panon qui rachète sa
concession à Jean-Julien en 1703 il
développe des plantations de café et
d'épices puis de canne à
sucre en
1911 le domaine est racheté par Albert
Chassagne qui lui donne sa physionomie
actuelle
il plante un double alignement de
palmier de part et d'autre de l'entrée
principale il fait reconstruire la
maison et ses dépendances agricoles bâti
une longère pour les ouvriers et
restructure l'immense verger situé à
l'arrière de la
maison ingénieur de formation Chassagne
dessine lui-même le plan de la nouvelle
maison les pièces qui s'organisent selon
un axe central donnent toutes sur l'une
des quatre varangues disposé sur chaque
façade habité jusqu'en 2012 la maison a
fait l'objet d'un important chantier de
rénovation en
2013 l'ancienne cuisine se situe à
l'arrière côté court comme il se doit
dans une maison créole
elle dispose un accès direct au potager
au
verger non loin de là se trouve les
longères autrefois occupé par les
engagés
indiens protégé au titre des Monuments
Historiques en raison de son
organisation spatial caractéristique de
l'architecture de plantation le grand
Asier est accessible à la visite tout au
long de
[Musique]
l'année